e
so for the committee I started my
morning down in our room looked a little
dis shuttled down there and uh but I I
sat up there not knowing that we weren't
meeting there and when I came back into
the uh elevator I came up with uh
represent Mills and we got off on the
third floor and I asked him why we were
coming here and he told me that's where
we're meeting today so so otherwise I
would have been the only person sitting
there in a few minutes when this
started we have again for the committee
we have a couple members that uh
um can't be with us
today um one is uh representative Jack
and the other is represent Kowski
Kowski uh with business kazinski with uh
business appointments and couldn't be
here so for um we certainly like to have
a full committee when we're doing naming
bills so I offer our apologies for not
providing that for you and as soon as we
the clerk back we will
Begin Again
oh I'm sorry yes you're showing as
eaten and
you're
e
for the members um for the members the
letters being distributed uh from the
chairman of the Hudson Board of
Selectmen in favor of what we're about
to hear uh the copy that I distributed
before which we have somewhere in our
records is has the town seal on it and
every everything else that's necessary
Sor
thank I think you're right
there
and
good morning um I would like to open up
the hearing on uh Senate Bill
468 um an act relative to designating a
portion of Route 111 in Hudson is the
Senator Robert E CLE Jr Memorial
Highway um with that I would like to
recognize Sandra
Carson thank you very much Mr chairman
and good morning and good morning um The
Honorable members of the house uh
Transportation committee um excuse me
I'm um wrong this is a public work in
Highway it was in transportation in the
Senate uh I have this morning uh excuse
me um my name is Sharon Carson and I
have the pleasure of representing uh
Senate District 14 comprising the towns
of Hudson London da and Auburn and I
have for your consideration uh Senate
Bill 468 which seeks to designate a
portion of Route 111 in Hudson as the
Senator Robert EC Jr Memorial Highway um
many people um knew Bob CLE served with
Bob CLE he was a member of the House for
a number of terms he served in the
Senate as well uh where he served as the
majority leader and um he didn't quite
get enough of politics he ran for
Congress and did not win and he came
back as a lobbyist and uh that's why I
think many people know who he is because
he was always talking with people um
unfort he unfortunately he passed away
very suddenly last year in August it
devastated his family and his friends
and everyone who knew him um I had the
pleasure of meeting Bob back in the
1990s my husband was a member of the new
house and I met him at political events
and I was elected in 2000 to the house
and my husband told me there's one
person you need to talk to and that's
Bob CLE and that's exactly what I did
and Bob became a good friend and a
mentor to me um for many many years um
he if I ever I had a question about
anything I could pick up the phone call
him and ask him and he always had an
answer he always had had an ADI uh any
kind of advice he was tuned in to the
legislature as I said he knew just about
everybody um he was he's just had Public
Service in his blood he was active in
his community as well when he passed he
was sitting on the town budget committee
um sometimes you might not have liked
what he had to say but he was always
honest he was always upfront with you
and if you had a question and he didn't
know the answer he'd say I let me find
out and I'll get back to you and he
would do that
um in thinking about Bob and everything
that he had done especially for me I was
thinking what's a good way to honor him
and that's when I thought about the a
portion of 111 I spoke to his family and
they are in complete support of us doing
this so um Unfortunately they couldn't
be here as well as a lot of Bob's
friends because they still find it very
very difficult to discuss his
passing
um so that's what you have in front of
you is just my my take on the whole
thing let's get a portion of 111 that
runs through the town of Hudson uh named
in his honor
um there is a cost as you know
Associated that with this and the last
time I had asked for a designation
usually the town will come out once they
choose a spot they will dig the hole but
I um I will be responsible for the pole
and the sign um that's how strongly I
feel about this but I'll I'll just leave
you with um a story um I talked with Bob
shortly before he became ill and he had
just become a new grandfather his
granddaughter was approaching her first
birthday and he talked extensively about
all the things he wanted to do with his
granddaughter and unfortunately he will
not be able to do these and I thought in
my opinion every time his uh family her
family goes through the town she can
point at that sign and say that's my pop
pop and I I just think that's such a
wonderful thing that we can do to honor
Bob um he Bob was a humble person we
found out after he died all the things
that he did to help people AC not not
even in his district but around the
state he supported
veterans um you named the cause he was
there and he if people were struggling
and they needed help whether it is
financially he would give them money I
most of us had no idea he was doing
these things and he did it quietly he
didn't want accolades he didn't want you
know people yeah had a boy Bob he just
did the things that needed to be done in
he did him quietly um unfortunately we
can't do this sign quietly it has to be
a public process and he'd probably be
you know what are you doing you don't
need to do this but I do think it's
appropriate to honor the man who gave so
much of himself uh to his community so
um I will end my testimony I'll be more
than happy to answer any
questions so thank you very much for
your time this morning Senator other
questions yes please repr Newton
yes thank you Mr Mr speak chairman and
thank you for taking my question would
you believe that I knew Bob C from the
late 90s also and that um he was a lot
of help for me and if he liked you he
played practical jokes on you would you
believe
that representative I would definitely
believe that because he did it to me all
the time would please follow up would
you also believe that in 2010 to 2012 I
was chairman of fishing game
and often I would come in and my name
tag would be missing and I'd have to go
to the clerk and say okay where did Bob
put my name tag today cuz he just would
do it all the time to me I knew it was
him and when I would see him he'd have a
he'd have a grin like a chesh a cat you
know that's a Bob I remember y thank you
thank you representative any further
questions for the Senator Senator thank
you for your testimony you very much Mr
chairman y um I'd like to move to uh
representative
Bob and I apologize I your handwriting
is where is HCI so thank you you and I
have something to work on yes welcome
welcome to Public Work sir thank you Mr
chair thank you honorable committee
members uh my name is for the record my
name is Robert warry I represent the
great uh town of Hudson which is the
10th largest population Center in New
Hampshire as well as uh renowned in days
of your for Benson's Wild Animal Farm
um I knew Bob after his political career
um while he was a lobbyist um the first
time I met him was at a uh
charitable uh dinner banquet auction and
um he is responsible for the most
expensive dessert I have ever had I'll
explain that um quite traditionally
every year he would um there would be
cakes for this auction this was for a
private school in the town of Hudson and
he would bid for these cakes and
sometimes the prices would go up quite
High and um and I was sitting at his
table um um whoever organized the event
always
put um Bob and I together along with our
families and so um he would then he
would buy this expensive dessert and he
would uh then say all right everybody
enjoy yourself I'm not taking this home
and he would pass out however many he
bought he to whoever was around there
this was typical of the generosity of
Bob CLE he
um Senator Carson mentioned you know
other accolades that he was known for I
I'll mention one other uh aspect he he
had a garden he he was my neighbor over
the hill he he and I lived the closest
between our two respective roads um his
property was over the Hill from mine and
he had a beautiful beautiful garden he
would often marry couples in that Garden
as a justice of the peace and I one
story I'll just relate that he shared
with me one time he used to see an older
couple just sitting in their car kind of
munching on sandwiches and finally got
you know was curious so he went and he
went out to what are why are you guys oh
well you know
you know we're retired we want to just
come by and your garden is so beautiful
we just wanted well why don't you just
get out of your car and sit the um sit
on the bench over there and enjoy is
that okay you know that he said of
course it's okay and um for many months
I I believe even years he's he's he
would see them come around occasionally
go there and and occasionally after she
passed he would see the man come there
and and memory of her so and that was
just the kind of guy he was he was
generous to a fault he he did play
practical jokes as you mentioned um a
wonderful guy um and very humble he
didn't he introduced himself as Bob hi
I'm Bob when I first met him so uh I can
relate that he was a wonderful person
and I would like um and encourage you to
support this bill as I do thank you
thank you are there any questions for
the
representative seeing none thank you and
I I do appreciate the stories thank
you um I have uh Dave is it Mazen or
Moren Moren
Moren here from the town of Hudson uh
sir welcome to public
works good morning chairman good morning
committee thank you for having me today
I appreciate it uh just just so the
record straight sir I'm the vice
chairman of the board of Select went
okay thank you
sir Senator Carson spoke about Mr Clay's
service to the state of New Hampshire
I'd like to talk about his service to
the town of Hudson I personally knew Bob
very well worked on many committees
within the town of Hudson's many groups
not only did he serve his community as a
legislator he was on Our Town Council he
served as a selectman he served on the
building Board of appeals and when he
passed away I served with him on the
town's budget committee he was a true
leader in our town and he worked very
hard to make Hudson the best place it
could be to live and to
work over the years heed numerous
recognitions from many of the Town
organizations such as the gra the fire
department uh Hillsboro County Home
Builders the American Legion we could go
on and on he he very much cared about
the town he very much cared about the
people in
Hudson and as the senator said and the
representative said he he tried to keep
all his his work very quiet and very
lowkey he served the Hudson the veterans
I'm a board of director for the Hudson
food pantry and the amount of work
donations and help that he has provided
to the people in need of Hudson goes
beyond I what I can talk about and
because of him the food pantry is very
successful and we we TR we can provide
our residents in need with everything
that they possibly could
want he helped out with Family Promise
in town he was a big donor for the
police department in town very big
supporter I was a firefighter in Hudson
for 32 years and during that time Mr C
made numerous donations and donated a
boat to the fire department which is
still in service today which has saved
countless lives has helped us make many
rescues and other protecting the marac
river and other water bodies in the town
of
Hudson he was
very involved in the Hudson toown home
uh sorry Hudson old homes day in local
schools I can go on and on with what Mr
CLE has done for the town of Hudson I
personally thought of him as a friend
was worked very close to together with
him and I think this would be a great
honor to to recognize him for everything
he's done for our town and the state of
New Hampshire I appreciate your time was
there anyone have any questions are
there any questions for the town
representative seeing none thank you sir
again thank you very much for your time
those are uh all of the pin cards I have
for U Senate Bill 468 if is there
someone that wishes to speak that hasn't
or someone that has spoken that wishes
to offer any further
testimony seeing none representative
cluder yes Mr chairman just have a
question I think there's a a
representative from do here and I have a
question related to this bill if you
don't certainly um thank you for coming
and just answering my question I just
want to be
sure this section of Road Route 11 to
your knowledge I don't if you've done
any research it's not named for anybody
else or any other organization is that
correct thank you for the question for
the record um Bill Lambert New Hampshire
dot I haven't done research specifically
on this but I not have no knowledge of
this section of 111 being uh named for
anybody else and I believe part of it is
within the compact for the town of
Hudson as well so it's split state and
town okay all right so that's what you
know okay all right thank you I just
don't I want to be sure we don't name it
for it's because it's already been named
with all due respect to Bob Clay yeah my
recollection is that prior to the the
bill um R Lea's on with the with the
legislature worked with Senator Carson
and others to make sure that that that
wasn't previously named okay thank you
Mr L any any further questions for Mr
Lambert Mr Lambert uh would you please
say your new title please uh the new
title is highway safety and Tra active
Transportation administrator I'd happy
to fill out a pink card if you'd like me
to all right I'm seeing none um we uh
typically as a um as a board do not uh
um come to a conclusion uh at the end of
a at end of a hearing but it is it is
policy for this committee um in honor of
um naming bills that we do so at this
time and so I would ask if they if we
have a motion so move Mr chairman
represent Boyd makes a motion seconded
by I'll I'll second that motion repres
cluder would you like to speak speak to
your most yeah yes I would Mr chairman I
certainly want to amplify the comments
that have been presented by Senator
Kason and my good colleague and
gentleman from Hudson representative ly
um regarding Bob CLE the only thing I
would add to it is Bob kle was one of
the first people I met when I moved to
New Hampshire and kind of laid the
landscape of everything that there was
regarding Civics and politics and
government here in the state of New
Hampshire and um I am very GR grateful
personally to his for his friendship and
for his mentorship and I think
dedicating a stretch of 111 is
absolutely apropo to honor the legacy of
Bob kle because like in meramac with our
former speaker dick hinch that sign us
there so that his grandson can see see
his name up on the highway and I think
it's befitting that that uh his
granddaughter be able to have the same
level of joy that Charlie Hench is going
to be experiencing so um that's what I'd
like to say to amplify the bill and I
thank you very much thank you represent
Boyd represent clud would you like to
speak to your second uh yes uh I second
this motion I knew Bob Cay a long time I
think when I first came to the to the
legislature at the time I believe he was
a fellow rep he also later became a
senator we didn't always see eye to eye
on every issue but I got along with him
personally and a few years ago he gave
me in an email I believe one of the best
compliments he said you're one of the
Reps who helps keep the house going and
I really one of the best compliments
I've ever received and I was honored
that he he uh gave me that compliment so
I fully support this Bill thank you any
other discussion prior to going into
executive
session motion is ought to pass on um
house or Senate Bill
468 as
introduced um seeing no questions no
debate uh when the clerk has an
opportunity we will call the role if
you're in favor of the motion signify by
saying I or and if you're opposed nay or
no thank you thank you Mr
chairman representative cluder
yes representative Mills votes yes
representative fedolfi
yes representative Newton yes
representative kazinski is excused
represent representative Bowden
yes representative Boyd Boyd votes
I representative Melvin yes
representative bogert yes representative
Connor
yes representative Jack is excused
representative Abbott
yes representative Edgar I
representative Faulkner
yes representative Newman yes
yes representative Eaton is excused
representative Peterson yes
representative vone is excused
representative jurus
yes chairman mccon I Mr shair the motion
ought to pass passes
160 Thank you I we I I'm not going to
suggest that we put it on the consent
calendar and the event that um family
wants to be in the gallery the day that
we uh we exec this bill or excuse me
when the house votes uh but I would like
ask the members if they could stand
please for a moment of silence in
recognition of our fellow legislator and
his
accomplishments thank
you
so we have we have uh five minutes 7
minutes before I believe 11:30 is our
next hearing and also a naming Bill uh
town of
Franklin so if you want to use this time
to use the facilities or whatever I'd
like to start promptly at 11:30 that'll
be the only business we conduct before
lunch and then we'll be coming back back
for
1:00
session do we
know
e
is there anyone here now that's uh going
to be speaking for Senate Bill
592 anyone from the town of
Franklin I wasn't going to all right
come on forward we have I believe we
have uh we have at least one sander
speaking that's
that's yes are you from the town sir
actually oh fantastic please this is 580
for later that's for later that's 580 we
got nobody nothing to 592 as of right
now I know that we have been
re
e
for those in attendance we had uh some
water damage sustained to our our room
down
2011 um and that work has not been
completed
so
our committee tables Works everything is
scattered throughout this building so we
sit here without a gavel and we sit not
in our room so uh mostly to my committee
members we also uh own the largest gavel
in the house other than the senator or
excuse me than the speaker of the house
so we're trying to run that down today
because it hasn't been seen for a couple
weeks so I hate to take away from your
message but I just the gavel is
important to this committee it is
indeed so I would like to open up uh
Senate Bill 592 renaming Route 12 27 on
Central Street in Franklin to the town
line of samton as officer Bradley is it
hos yes hos Memorial uh Highway and I
would like to rep like to recognize H
inis to uh to uh begin all right thank
you Mr chair good morning good morning
Mr Vice chair members of the committee
um thank you for having me this morning
uh I'm here today to introduce uh Senate
Bill 592 FN
and uh Bradley hos who was 63 at the
time was working as a security officer
at the New Hampshire hospital in conquer
when as you know a gunman opened fire in
the front lobby despite efforts to save
Mr hos he died of his injuries he worked
for the Department of Safety at the time
of the shooting and before that he spent
28 years with the Franklin New Hampshire
Police Department starting as a patrol
officer and eventually being named chief
he retired from the Department in 2008
he was also a veteran of the US Army and
I'd like to share a quote from New
Hampshire Attorney General John formella
who said Chief hos was already a hero
when he walked into work that day given
his service to our country to our state
and to his community he will now be
remembered as a man who died protecting
patients staff and visitors at the New
Hampshire Hospital Bradley grew up in
Franklin and attended Franklin High
School he went on to serve his country
as a military police officer in the US
Army before becoming an officer in his
hometown town of Franklin he served his
community for 26 years as a respected
officer and leader and he became the
chief of police for the city of Franklin
after retirement Brad worked for the US
Postal Service and then as a security
officer for the State of New Hampshire
at the New Hampshire hospital while I
was never fortunate enough to meet Brad
people I have talked with said he was a
kind and loving person who was committed
to his family his friends his community
his State and indeed his Nation this is
all Illustrated in his career and in his
service importantly Brad enjoyed time
with his son and they had much in common
as a father and son often do Brad was
always there to help everyone that's who
he was we can never understand senseless
acts like what happened to Mr
hos it's hard to
process and nothing that we can say or
do will bring him back but we can
remember Bradley hos and I'm pleased to
bring this bill forward to name a
portion of New Hampshire 127 as the
Bradley House Memorial Highway Brad
traveled this segment of Highway often
almost daily and his heroic life his
love of his fellow citizens his
protective Mission will always be
remembered and this honorific naming I
hope will be a part of those fond
memories may God bless Mr Bradley hos
his family and his friends I'm happy to
take any questions if you have some
thank you Senator are there questions of
the
senator okay seeing none thank you for
for your remarks thank you
sir the other speaker I have is
um
Steve
hton Mr hooton I thank you please come
forward make yourself comfortable you're
a family member and we would love to
hear your your thoughts sir welcome to
public works thank you
for
yeah first
time uh it's a little difficult so may
take me a minute um it is up here too
sir so take your time so I was Brad's
former brother-in-law um he was married
to my sister for a little over a decade
uh blessed us with Connor his son um
also had the opportunity to serve in
samton Police Department uh next to
Chief ha's uh police department and
witness the the wonderful work that he
was doing for that City the significance
of Route 127 is Brad's family moved
there in 1970 to Victory Drive in
Franklin um and he traveled that that
road daily to B school and then
continuing on to work um in the early
1990s Brad bought a house further up on
New Hampton Road uh also in Franklin on
127 and continued to travel that road uh
to and front from Franklin Police
Department every day after marrying my
sister they bought a home in samton
which if you're familiar it was just
just up the road from the general store
again required him to travel Route 127
every single day so from 1970 until 2008
um Brad traveled that section of road
from samton to to Franklin uh daily that
is the significance of that portion of
the road uh I was pleased that Senator
Ernest picked up the ball and ran with
it it uh it meant a lot to the family um
it is fully supported by his family I
was with his his son my nephew Monday
night handing off a uh an actual signed
roll call from the Senate and a letter
from Senator inis to to the HW family
um just a moment take all the time you
need
sir regrettably um Brad's mother passed
a week ago um but again the families
were close uh very supportive of all the
efforts and very thankful for the
recognition should it
occur that is all I have pending any
questions thank you sir are there any
questions seeing none I um I just would
like to explain to you and your
family
um I and everyone else has touched here
on on what happened here and then also
the passing of your other family member
it is policy of this committee on the
naming and I'm I um that we have a
letter from the town with the affected
Highway change and the senator has told
us that they've been in
conversation and that there's a letter
being generated to that effect but in no
disrespect whatsoever for officer hos we
will not exec this today we will do it
next week and we will give um we will
give full notice so if the family uh
wants to attend when it's brought to the
house floor we'll provide that
opportunity understood and appreciated
thank
you um my question for
do
um is um Mr Lambert are are you aware of
any um pream of this stretch of
highway thank you Mr chairman and once
again Bill Lambert New Hampshire do um
127 runs from a Route 9 in hopkington
Haner to sden um I'm not aware of any
segment of that being named so that that
would include this segment thank you uh
I would like to uh take a moment if we
could stand as a committee one more time
for a moment of silence recognizing the
achievements in the life of off Bradley
hos thank you please pass our regrets Mr
chair before we uh we should read the
blue sheet I forgot to do so previous
hearing we could just pass that
along thank
you
blue sheet um shows uh Mr Lambert New
Hampshire Department of dot in
favor and the gentlemen uhon that just
spoke also being in
favor we will be in recess till
1:00
e
that
Waters give me one moment to get set up
here and then we'll get
started
well I guess I'm going to see you in a
little while all right Friday the Good
Friday I'll See You Good
Friday yeah yeah
yeah time being being nearly 1:00 we
will uh open up the hearing for Senate
Bill 470 FN relative allowing toll for
use of vehicles registered with
Municipal
plates and um before I recognize Senator
Wars I would just like to welcome you to
Public Works in our new temporary digs
where we are thank you uh thank you for
attending and with that would you please
uh provide your testimony uh thank you
Mr chairman members of the committee I'm
senator David Waters District 4
introducing Senate Bill 470 relative to
allowing toll free use for vehicles
registered with Municipal place it's
nice to see you all and it's nice to be
in this room because I spent four years
in this room on fishing games so it's
very familiar to me if not to you not to
you all um this bill is at the request
of the department and it puts into
statute a program that had been underway
for quite some time in which there is a
compact between Dot and municipalities
to uh allow the use of toll-free
transponder at the uh on on
Municipal uh vehicles and uh we've been
doing it for quite some time and thought
gee it ought to be in statute and it
should and so that's what the bill does
to see this amendment um existing
program and uh just as a note the
municipalities will be required to pay
the
$6.50 to the Department of
Transportation for the uh non-tool
transponder that is the bill Mr chairman
I'd be glad to take any questions we
have questions for the
senator this is too
easy right briefly U briefly the um any
Municipal
vehicle thanks for your question uh it's
with the municipal plates I do think dot
can explain what the universe of that is
but it has to be official Municipal
vehicle thank you any further
questions uh yes represent Mills just
one I'm just curious Senator because I
wasn't aware that this even existed how
long do we think that this agreement has
been going on without
legislation any
ideas yes the if you don't mind I mean
he'll be up but sorry I'm John cor Min
of I'll
beying um well if you if you can cover
it then later I'll I'll I'll drop the
question for right now thank you Senator
but you know who to th it we're doing
something it wasn't in the statute but
it's good to have it in
statute thank you uh Senator appreciate
your
testimony and we will move to Mr Cochran
New Hampshire
dot good afternoon chairman and members
of the committee my name is John corkran
I'm an administrator of Bureau turnpikes
under the Department of Transportation
I'm here to testify in support of the
bill um the department also appreciates
sener water sponsor the bill for us um
presently in law municipalities are
exempt from tolls with similar to state
government vehicles school buses uh
federal government
legislators and County Sheriffs and US
military what the change in this bill is
um there has been a change with
municipalities that they're getting um
passenger plates now instead of mpal
plates and to continue with the law we
decided we recommend a change to say any
missal register Vehicles get the free
toll and a lot of it's dealing with the
transponders that Senator Waters talked
about um any any one of these state
agencies municipalities they come to us
we um sell them the non-rev transp
transponders but in the past they had a
municipal plate but now there's been a
change these passenger plates so now
they give us proof of the registration
as municipality and then we sell them
the
transponders Thank you Rich Mills did
you have a question no it was answered
thank you and um I before before I go to
represent fauler um is it a different
color than the no it's orange it's
orange transponder just like probably
all of you have one too yeah thank you
represent
pner
so the tollfree is only available on a
vehicle that has Municipal plates so if
the municipality obtains a
transponder they're obliged to use it
only on a particular vehicle or only on
a one of the vehicles that has Municipal
plates is there a way to
enforce they're not using it for private
uh travel by by employees for
example um we can't enforce that but
there has been like we have an agreement
with the vipal and it says it's only for
municipality um um Vehicles you can't
use it outside of New Hampshire you know
if you went to mass um we've had not a
mpal but some people who' buy these from
us we get information when they're
questioning if their employees are using
it outside and we pass it on to them but
that's up to them and their rules of how
they handle
that any further questions for the
Department yes please thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question you have an idea of how many
vehicles we're talking about
um if we allow this um I'm not sure how
many every municipality has different um
number of vehicles but this has been in
law for years like there's no Revenue
impact to us it was always going by
their plates missable plates um but
their plate some reason within DMV now
when they registered Vehicles it's a
passenger plate like our like a typical
plate that like I have on my vehicle and
and this law is just changing it to
allow those because they're registered
to the town um they show us proof of
insurance proof of registration at it's
a municipal
vehicle thank
you thank you any further questions for
the Department yes represent chairman I
just want to be clear here although they
can with the transponders go through the
tolls for free I believe there's a fee
for the transponders which they have to
pay yes yes correct current fee it's um
around $6 right now $6 right now okay as
of today and is it is it probably you
anticipate rais in the next few years or
when was it last raise um usually
they're going down surprisingly yeah so
okay so right now it's $6 okay I want to
be clear on that thank you yeah and they
every transponder they purchase they
cost $6 for them with how much again
every transponder is $6 each $6 to make
so it's just at Cost corre all right
okay thank you for that information and
there is anou with us in them that um
they sign and then we sign too which
shows the responsibility with them with
these transponders similar to not
letting their employees use it on their
own vehicles on their own Vehicles their
personal vehic yeah all right thank you
yes represent J thank you Mr chairman
thank you just so city of Manchester
comes to your your department and says
we need six of these and they give you
the plate numbers
and yes log them in in the registrations
and then we have the agreement with them
and they sign it we sign it then they
they purchase the transponders thank you
thank you thank
you thank you sir appreciate your
time uh we have we have no other um pink
cards okay and I just if there's any
people sign the blue sheet yes blue
sheets great job yeah I remembered this
time Senator Waters got out of here
before we could find out about a missing
picture from fishing game so we'll
follow up with that
okay okay thank
you Kathleen heel New Hampshire
Municipal Association I'm I know I'm
mispronouncing
that and
John Corran that just testified both in
support so uh we had talked earlier
about this um I had spoken with the
chairman um it seems to be pretty
straightforward what we're doing here
just legislating a practice that's
already gone um represent cluder do you
feel comfortable executing this bill at
this time if it's just codifying
something I don't have a problem uh
myself okay and I haven't heard any
objections from anybody else on the
committee are there any committee
objections that if we were to move
forward with us give you a little more
time that you don't have to come back
here uh do I um do I have a represent
cler do I have a
motion uh okay I will make a motion of
ought to pass on a house bill okay what
the bill number I'm sorry uh six excuse
me 477 thank you very much I couldn't
remember the
motion um motion I'm sorry I heard Boyd
second okay um cluder and Boyd is a
second uh motion's been made is there
discussion so if you're in favor of the
motion to um to ought to pass on 470
Senate Bill 470 uh you'll signify by
saying I or or yes if you are opposed to
this leg islation nay or
no and I threw that pretty quick at you
there Mr clerk when you're ready please
call the role thank you Mr chair
representative cluder
yes representative Mills votes yes
representative fidie yes representative
Newton yes kazinski is excused
representative Bowden
yes representative Boyd Boyd votes I
representative Melvin
yes representative bogert yes
representative Connor
yes representative Jack is excused
representative Abbott yes representative
Edgar I representative Faulkner
yes representative Newman
yes representative Eaton is excuse
representative Peterson
yes representative Fon is excused rep
representative jurus
yes chairman mccon hi Mr chair the
motion ought to pass passes
160 Thank you any objection well there
is it does have an FN on it but I don't
believe that there was a does anyone
have leg is there a physical note
actually attack to no so there's no
impact so any objection to going on
consent
seeing none we'll put it on
consent okay we have one one more
hearing um at 1:30 Senate Bill
580 um and we will be in recess until
then
this should be an interesting one wonder
if we have much coming in on
it she's the only car so far she's the
only car
yeah
is it R richardi ricardi she's
new
i c it out of
my
so this is the
calendar so we have no bills
tomorrow
e
Senator we'll start in just a couple
minutes
e
uh welcome I would like to open up the
1:30 hearing for Senate Bill 580
FN authorizing the sale of toll credits
to fund a newly established noise
barrier construction fund for the design
and construction of noise barrier
projects and I uh before I welcome the
prime sponsor I'd like to say it all
here we are in our temporary housing for
uh Public Works and highways and I want
to welcome you Senator uh for joining us
here and I'd like to recognize uh
Senator Rashard Rashard perfect thank
you close I had help uh and uh please uh
please present your legislation thank
you good afternoon chairman and members
of the House Public Works and highways
committee I'm Denise rardy I'm the state
senator for District 9 representing 13
beautiful towns from Bedford all the way
to
Hinsdale um before I actually read my my
introduction to you I want to give a
little bit of a background around so
what prompted this legislation to begin
with is that I have a neighborhood um in
my district in Bedford tberry Lane and
they were there long before you know we
had the highway and then the highway
kept growing and growing and I'm telling
you if you go to their houses and you
stand in their driveway you can't even
hear yourself think when we've met I
have to make arrangements for us to go
to the Bedford police station and meet
in the conference room or the town hall
it is horrible that they have to live
like this and the problem with um them
not being allowed a noise barrier is the
criteria in our policies which say that
although the decibel is within the
allowable amount for noise barrier the
density is not so for example if that
was an apartment building instead of
people's homes that they've lived there
for 60 years they would be able to get
the noise barrier and it's been an
ongoing problem long before I was even
in the Senate here and trying to find a
proper solution has not been easy so now
I'll read my testimony to you because
there is a solution here that I hope
you'll be able to
support um Senate Bill 580 presents a
proactive solution to address noise
pollution concerns across our state by
creating the noise barrier construction
fund the fund will provide vital
resources for completion of noise
barrier construction projects that meet
type two noise barrier criteria as
determined by the Department of
Transportation one of the key provisions
of Senate Bill 580 is the authorization
for the commissioner of the Department
of Transportation to sell up to 10
million in toll credits annually
provided there are sufficient credits
available for the state to match Federal
uh uh portion and upon a proper approval
and compliance with all regul ations
this Innovative approach will generate
much needed funding for noise barrier
construction projects without imposing
an additional financial burden on our
taxpayers by establishing the noise
barrier construction fund and leveraging
toll credits this bill will empower the
Department of Transportation to properly
address noise pollution effectively and
efficiently moreover this amendment will
provide municipalities throughout the
state with an opportunity to receive
noise barriers construction when needed
enhancing the quality of life for
residents in the affected areas in
conclusion Senate Bill 580 represents a
proactive and fiscally responsible
approach to mitigating noise pollution
and improving the well-being of our
communities I urge the members of this
committee to support this bill and
ensure its passage for the benefit of
our state I thank you for your attention
in this matter again this is for me
quality of life life your home is your
Castle you have a right to live there in
peace and enjoy your home and your
families and we haven't been able to
find a solution that works cost-wise and
there are many of other towns in many of
your districts I'm sure that have the
same problem so this will really benefit
um all of our constituents and uh can
answer any questions and I also the
commissioner here who can answer even
more questions for you if you like
so thank you thank thank you
Senator would you believe this committee
members are are very familiar with the
tberry lane we' we've been discussing
this over the course of many years uh
questions for the senator from the
committee yes represent J thank you Mr
chairman Senator this example on tberry
and I is it this neighborhood along the
ever Turnpike yes okay on the sbound yes
okay thank you and if I may also add
that you know originally it wouldn't it
wouldn't be appropriate with what you
probably saw in the past which is to
just demand that noise barriers go in
for tberry so trying to find a solution
that would help all people throughout
our state um this was the best example
and very different from what you've
probably seen in the past
years thank you uh represent mil yes
thank you Senator um do you happen to
know uh and I'm going I'm only asking
this because you said you'd been you've
been there uh what type of uh length
we're talking about that this noise
Berry would have to be a mile mile and a
half to any idea at all I believe um I
don't know in miles but I'm going to say
it impacts about 20 25 homes okay thank
you so it's pretty significant um and I
I I honestly ly if you have any doubt go
over there and stand in one of their
driveways you would be you would not
want I always try to put myself in
everyone else's shoes and let me tell
you I wouldn't want to live there okay
thank you further
questions yes please represent Newman
yes th thank you just say for argument
sake that there's I'll say 12 um areas
with within the state that would like to
have sound barriers you your situation
being one of them how would you envision
this fund saying okay you get it and
you're next on the list and whatever
well the way the bill is created it's
going to be handled by the commissioner
and the Department of
Transportation so I think there will be
a um a fair and balanced way to
determine how this should go thank you
thank you any further further questions
for the senator represent jge follow
thank you Mr chairman and in this
example
with with the wide is is the tberry
neighborhood going to be affected even
more due to the widening of that's going
on is it in that location of the
widening as well yes they they've been
constantly impacted and the the
Department of Transportation tried to do
their best by putting up a a Stockyard
fence which didn't do much for sound but
at least afforded some privacy but then
it you know it rotted it fell down um I
can tell you one of the neighbors
he couldn't get out of his garage
because people decided that his driveway
would be a good Park and Ride there's
been people um coming to their homes
stealing gas cans um it it's been a
safety issue Beyond just that um the
department now is um it's been a long go
it's we've been talking about it for a
year but they are trying to put up a
better getting the permits to put up a
little bit better of a fence and maybe
some shrubbery
um but it's a pretty pretty rough
situation thank you any further
questions for the
senator seeing none thank you for your
time well thank you for your time and
I'm I left caucus to come here so I'm
going to rush out thank you we do
appreciate your time a copy yeah theator
Senator do you have a copy of your
testimony oh yeah yeah just we'll take
scribbles and everything thank
you all right I would like to uh uh
bring
um commissioner Cass forward perhaps we
could ask some
[Music]
questions uh thank you Mr chairman Bill
Cass commissioner of the Department of
Transportation with me is John Evans who
is our uh noise specialist in the um
Bureau of uh environment um he can
answer any details uh about
noise analysis how we how we do our
studies about our policy and um you know
I can ask any general questions about
the financing funding toll credits Etc
so thank you uh before we do I would
just like to acknowledge the lady
sitting in the back row Kathleen and who
offered me a tremendous amount of time
to help pull together and uh correct uh
my house buil 2024 to make sure that we
had correct numbers and I I always speak
how well the staff does but I I just
want to just say special thank you right
here to uh to that lady yeah thank you
all right M rep Mr
Cass so how are how are we doing with
toll credits overall and our uh we
always knew that we had a mountain of
them and by using them it lessened how
much road work we could get done because
it wasn't a cash
contribution so are we are we
experiencing still a climbing amount of
toll credits have have we reached a peak
and we're seeing less how how how is our
audit of toll
credits uh yes yeah so I have the most
current um spreadsheet in front of me
that we that we um uh submit the Federal
Highway annually as as we review our um
our our our use of of Turnpike toll
credits and uh so we are on a decline uh
when you mention a a mountain so I've
got the um my spreadsheet dates back to
1992 when we first really started in
Earnest pursuing the uh utilization of
toll credit so we went from a high in
around
200 uh 14 of a little over $300 million
the current balance of uh Turnpike toll
credits is about $186
million from a um use and utilization
standpoint
um when I look at say the last um for
the last three years we've used between
$40 and $50 million annually of Turnpike
toll credits to match our uh our our
federal program um in that same time
frame we have we have claimed approved
uh
between between 35 and 45 million do so
on average in the last three years our
utilization outweighs what we're what
we're gaining and that's primarily
because the um and we talked about it
with the 10-year plan that that the the
turnpike expenditures um are are are not
as robust as they had been in the past
as um um revenues have have declined and
we're kind of more in a a one project at
a time versus a a more robust Capital
program there so um hopefully that
answers answers your answers your
question but um we haven't done a
projection as much ahead but I I can say
it has been a it has been a scramble um
to meet the maintenance of effort that
that is required to claim ter Turnpike
toll credit so
in the last
um in the
last we have been able to claim total
credits in the last four years but for
the three previous years uh because of
the maintenance of effort we hadn't been
able to I for see that being a challenge
in in the future as well too being able
to um claim Turnpike toll credits so
before I open it up to other questions
[Music]
so we we all know we all know the
difficulty of um receiving Revenue to
handle the mission you have the policy
you have um and
turnpikes
um I guess my question is irregardless
of whether this this idea moves
forward and we know that we have a need
for a new funding source or we need to
come together together with the Senate
and find you know some some relief here
legislatively because people want their
roads and highways and their Bridges
working how long at the current rate of
expenditure with money coming in do you
you expect that you would have toll
credits for that benefit so you're
you're spending more than over the last
four years you're spending more than you
have coming in correct right is it a
concern to
you uh uh yes yes it is it is a concern
um if if it goes on at at at at this
rate so if I look at like the last
threeyear average we're we're we're
probably um about a $10 million a year
deficit on average um if that if that
continues you know $189 million of the
current current balance will would would
extend for some time
um no knowing knowing the tentativeness
of the of the turnpike financing
situations particularly with regard to
the capital program um I think that that
that's going to be a it's going to be a
challenge to meet the maintenance of
effort in which case then uh we wouldn't
be able to claim Turnpike toll credits
and our spend rate would be in that $45
to $50 million a year to match the the
federal program um if that scenario came
about the present balance would would
only be sufficient for four or five
years that's a that's a stark reality to
me um now if if I could switch gears so
I and
um I wasn't here for that presentation
this year but I'm sure the
U um the majority of the members here uh
realize the struggle that the department
has had to date on how to fund outside
of the U of the cost of the highway and
the federal eligibility of
where um sound barriers could be
constructed there's a much larger need
than what we are and tberry we've been
talking about for years and and with the
I
apologize with the um not meeting
eligibility to be able to pull those
funds and not having the enormous cost
typically to construct those barriers
that we don't have money in our 10-year
plan to do it
either is this proposal as it's being
brought forward is is this possible to
even
do um under uh under these
credits um would this which require a
federal change in regulations well one
of the issue what what this hinges on is
is What's called the toll toll credit
Marketplace so in the last
reauthorization there was um there was
language that would approve the
establishment of a toll credit
marketplace where if we had or some
other state had excess toll credits that
we didn't need to match match our our
our program we could go to some
Marketplace and other other states could
buy our toll credits other states that
were probably that were say having
trouble matching their their federal
dollars because they didn't have enough
State dollars or something so um that
was the concept that was the idea so
technically there is uh the
establishment of a toll credit
Marketplace within the
reauthorization there has not been so
the ability to establish a toll credit
Market places in the legislation there
haven't been steps to establish that
Marketplace so presently the short
answer to your question is no presently
there isn't Federal
authorization um I don't know if it
requires rul making or or or something
to implement what is in the
authorization but um presently there
isn't a toll credit Marketplace to take
advantage of that's not to say that at
some point in the future that that that
that may get um
established and final question for
myself I'm not I'm not one that ever
bought into Bitcoin so I'll just thr
right out there it would it would see it
would seem to me that if we were to put
toll credits out there in this market if
there was to be an auction at that point
it would seem to me that what we
wouldn't get more revenue for those
through the this process then what we
can have for
value with our own state would there
be am I incorrect in that are people
paying above market rate for those no no
I don't think so I think you are correct
I mean I I I I don't know what values
there would be but I think it
was it was
assumed that any any any any toll credit
Marketplace the the the value of the
credits would somehow be be be
discounted and in other words if
somebody bought $100 of toll credits for
they bid against in this Marketplace but
the it certainly wouldn't be greater
than the face value I I I think the
benefit would be if uh thank you for
that so and um I'll break my own rule
here of course so how much how much
money or tool credits is anticipated in
this
proposal is it is it open for
I think the toll credits are estimated
to sell up to 10 $10 million per year um
in compliance with Federal rules and
regulations um the one the one part
about this bill that that I do like is
it does um it does
um if you look at uh lines four and five
there the very first part does talk
about uh provided that there are
sufficient Turnpike toll credits for the
state match for the federal
apportionment totals for 5 years based
on the current fiscal year and the
preceding four so I probably reading
that I tried to give you like the last
the the the last five years of of
average and stuff and and based on our
um based on that at the present time I I
you know I I don't think we would have
the availability of of toll credits to
um put aside $10 million a year if there
was a Marketplace but that's at current
time um I I do think the bill does uh uh
recognize an issue that that that that
has been um on a lot of people's minds
as far as a a way to fund um uh sound
barriers and mitigate highway highway
noise
um so if if anything at least th this
bill does signal uh an an intent that uh
it is that it is a um an an issue and an
attempt to find some way to uh find find
a way to fund fund them whether this
mechanism is is appropriate in the short
or long term um is questionable I think
thank you and I and I agree with your
statment questions for the
commissioner yes uh represent
foli just pull that a little closer to
you do we have any idea what this
project will cost the state of New
Hampshire uh this this this bill
specific or this specific
project I mean th this bill I saw a
figure over here that said Point
represent could you just pull the mic a
little closer to you someone assist the
representative just pull what bothers me
is the last paragra hold hold your
comment
suspend There You Go sir all
right the last paragraph This is a hugee
question mark on the final cost of this
whole
project
well the I mean the the the bill is
amended by the Senate talks about
spending $10 million a year in toll
credits to put toward a program to fund
sound walls I know Senator richardi was
talking
specifically about uh T tberry Lane and
and that was the impetus uh behind this
bill but uh I as it as it was amended by
the Senate it doesn't
specifically fund
uh tberry Lane if that if that's what
you're asking yeah this I'm asking yeah
this bill do we have any idea what the
final cost is going to be to the
taxpayers of New Hampshire pure and
simple so we can by the limits
establishing the bill it would be um you
know to sell up to $10 million per year
in Turnpike toll credits and whatever
revenue from the sale of that $10
million we would put toward this
program so I explained to uh chairman
mcon you know the the final value if if
this was implemented would would be
dependent on the sale of those $10
million of of um toll credits but
um it would be I think at a at an an
expense of that that Val that credit
value of $10 million so I think it is a
fairly established cost as as relayed in
the Senate amended
Bill thank you further questions yes
represent pulner
please I maybe reasing the question that
representative vvi asked but at one time
didn't we we
were a session or two ago we were
looking at a total program of of uh you
know perhaps a hundred places where
noise barriers might be listed might be
created and that list was in some kind
of priority order do we have an idea of
how big that list is and you know and
apparently there there's some point at
which anything below that is no longer
cost effective and wouldn't wouldn't be
eligible is have we estimated that as
part of this uh this bill um I don't
know if we've estimated as part of this
bill but you are correct we have done it
in the past John has the spreadsheet in
front of them um I could speak off
recollection do you do you want in Broad
figures what we have for estimate and
and again this isn't
necessarily specific to to to the bill
but we have identified what the what
the um overall kind of
um needs are you know Statewide
so thank you so um it's it as you can
imagine it's it's a little bit difficult
to to directly answer that because
there's there's certain barriers that
may or may not be eligible and so back
in 2017 we did a did a study to to
identify all the potential locations
throughout the state that had
about uh 260 locations throughout the
state that that have homes within
approximately 500 feet of the highway so
that's that's kind of and and we're
talking you know the the tier one
highways throughout the state so so that
that would be um you know essentially
the the the potential locations but not
all of those have necessarily noise
impacts but but in in general and you
are correct that you at a certain point
you start dropping off the list of being
eligible for our policy as it as it's
written now and qualifying for federal
funds and and and whatnot but it's in
the ballpark of about um at our current
rates it would probably if every barrier
were built that would
be that is
anticipated to be eligible and then and
and I say this with the caveat that this
was a planning study and it's not um it
it it doesn't make a formal
determination of Eligibility but it
would be approximately at current
costs
about
million so
um that gives you a rough idea of what
what that would
cost
thank you yes please
representative thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my questions I got
a couple questions
if depending on the answers uh will this
fund be used to fund non-term pipe
projects as far as these noise barriers
are
concerned I yes I believe that would be
the intent our type two program is uh
and and this reference is kind of the
type two policy
um is um is based on on on needs um
along both the interstate and the
Turnpike system follow um I could be
wrong and probably am but I thought the
tolls that were taken were only used for
Turnpike projects so selling to me if
you're selling a toll
credit that would be encumbered into the
same thing
as collecting tolls so how do we have
the mechanism to take Turnpike money and
start to pay for non-
Turnpike items if you understand what
I'm asking y I do and and maybe it's a a
brief explanation of what the turnpike
toll credit is so while it has Turnpike
in its name the turnpike toll credit is
a recognition by by the federal
government of the investment we make in
state State dollars in the turnpike
system so because we invest State
dollars Turnpike dollars only in the
turnpike system we are able to claim a
credit on the federal federal side so um
we earn a credit with the federal
government that we can put towards our
federal um match requirements so while
it is earned or generated based on the
investment in the turnpike system it
really is more of a of a credit to our
uh um a credit to the match requirement
of our federal
program okay follow up one more follow
yes you may uh thank you Mr chairman now
in the bill it says 10
million dollars worth of credits is that
retail value at 10 million or is that
the
net equaling 10 million I'm kind of I
would interpret that as so we have on
the books a certain value of Turnpike
toll credits so I would I would equate
that as um essentially the face value of
those of those Turnpike toll credits
whether that $10 million in in toll
credits on this
Marketplace um translates into $10
million of of of value or or something
less I think that was the question that
representative mcon was getting at um
but I would view it as $10 million of
face value of of toll credits and
whatever value we could get for it um on
whatever Marketplace is establish likely
it would be some usable cash value of
less than the $10 million credit but
okay one last fin question yes thank you
I appreciate your uh patience
um the last one is if this bill is
successful and uh you're able to set up
this $10 million
fund then you will at some point create
a
list and prioritize this
list yes so the ex I'm assuming this
methodology they used here is an as an
example and doesn't guarantee it's first
priority or is this automatically first
priority and then we move on to the rest
of the
list uh I'm not sure what you meant by
by what's established here it's first
priority this this references a lot of
our type two policy Lane Priority One or
not I would say no no even though even
though that is the impetus of of of the
bill the bill text doesn't reference
specifically tberry Lane it talks about
a type two policy um which does have
some other matching requirements that
that we look to also have some um
Community investment and participation
and ownership um as as well too so we do
have a prioritized list um there also
has to be uh local community support um
as well thank you repr Mills thank you
Mr chair uh this is just for the benefit
of most of the committee that hasn't
heard this as many times as some of us
has uh the sound barriers are still
approxim
L cost is about a million dollar a mile
is that is that still a current to you
John do you have more current
uh we typically don't calculate it based
upon mile um so it's a it's more about
uh because it it it some some need to be
taller than others so and and they're
approximately $100 per square foot the
average barrier is 16t um you know so
so you could you could kind of do the
math from there but um that's what dot
is for
that's we've we've always had the math
of a million dollars a mile a million
dollars a mile so I just want to know if
it changed at all it's likely higher
than that but likely higher thank
you thank you represent representative
Abbott please yes um as my memory serves
me right there is a lifespan on these
sound barries too is that correct
correct however we have um I don't know
if any of you have driven down uh i93
lately we've actually just started
installing uh we changed our no current
noise barrier design to a one with a
concrete uh panel rather than a wood
panel and one of the main reasons behind
that is it does have a longer life
expectancy we believe it to be about in
the in the ballpark of 100 years versus
the uh the the wood panels are 25 to 30
years so thank
you uh we'll stay there represent
fauler can you help me understand who it
is who's going to be buying these
credits is
it my imagination is that the
municipality needs to provide a
match of say a million
dollars and if we can buy a million
dollars worth of toll credits for half a
million then
it's in business but does that
really does that increase or decrease
the amount of of construction that we
can actually do in the state of the you
know total Municipal and state
level uh from from from the municipal
side or the the or the state side
whoever is whoever is buying toll
credits or what do they right how is
that an advantage and are they able to
build more right as a result of this
program I think the advantage it's it's
like it's like you know some some of the
advantage to New Hampshire we we have
had um uh we have been fortunate in the
past 10 years or so to have a very um
robust Turnpike Capital program um and
and that has has generated uh uh a
sufficient amount of Turnpike toll
credits where we don't put very much if
any state funds in to match our federal
program so we match all of our most all
of our federal dollars we use Turnpike
toll credits to to to meet the federal
match requirement so um on on on the one
on the one hand uh you know from a
budget perspective and and we're coming
up on budget budget season next year and
stuff you know that that takes care of
you know this past year FY 23 we used
$49 million of of of Turnpike toll
credit to match our federal program
that's $50 million of State funds that
we didn't have to find in a budget
somewhere to enable um our federal
program to go to go forward so that's on
on the one hand on the other hand it
also means we did if if if we had
matched that Federal program with with
with Hard Cash instead of toll credits
we would have done $50
million more work so it's it's it's uh
you know depending where the priorities
and needs and and and things are as that
as far as who would use them I mean I
know for
example um again we uh you know New
Jersey has has has a very you know
robust Turnpike program they have a lot
of Turnpike toll credits um they would
be we would be potentially sellers there
are states like Vermont that have no
Turnpike uh program they have a lot of
federal
and I know you know one of Vermont's um
challenges has been
um uh raising enough State funds to be
able to meet their um Federal match
requirements and Avail themselves of all
of their available federal funds because
they don't their challenge is they don't
have enough State funds to match the
federal dollars so a state like Vermont
potentially you know purchasing Turnpike
toll credits would be um of Interest
particularly if they could
would acquire them for 80 cents on the
dollar or something like that so
hopefully that answers your
question yeah fur further questions yes
please representative Newman yes uh
thank you you mentioned earlier you got
to look at a decibel versus a density
situation is that's a federal um uh
standard uh
tell me if I do it wrong it's uh F the
federal doesn't establish a standard
they require us to have a a a policy now
there are federal standards on the um on
the deciel
threshold um we set our own
reasonable criteria which which gets
into the which gets into the density
okay so and I I know I've testified in
the past in our past review of other
states policies you know New Hampshire
is we
are pretty well in the middle of of the
pack I know there are other states like
um Maryland comes to mind which has a
very uh a lower threshold and they're um
they build a lot more sound walls Maine
has a much higher threshold and uh if
you if you drive up the Maine Turnpike
or or or Road there um it's it's very
difficult to meet their threshold they
they they
they build very few sound walls um so um
so we by policy have established kind of
a middle of the road um reasonableness
criteria the decibel criteria is
established by federal requirements is
that right yeah correct I apologize I
used the wrong word policy because I can
I have in my memory here I can remember
hearing about this and and it was very
detailed and I mean a lot of you all put
a lot of thought into the whole thing
when you put it out I'm going to depend
on your memories also several I'm
thinking several years ago I remember a
woman coming in she was from the Sea
Coast Area and they had been waiting
some 30 years for sound barriers and you
know and she um just say if everything
was perfect whatever where would that
situation be waiting for over 30 years
now compared to T Berry Lane would one
be ahead of
another
um it might depend on the the location
in Portsmouth but um if it's we're
actually we're in the process of of uh
we'll be uh advertising a project to
build two sound barriers in Portsmith
okay uh that will advertise next month
um and it's probably the the
neighborhood that you're thinking of
it's the The panaway Manor neighborhood
in okay thank you for the good M and so
that was ranked I believe it was
somewhere in the ballp park
of I can't find it right off hand but
it's it was up there it was probably
number it was in the top 10 or so list
tberry Lane
is
106 and I would say it's not by the um
by the age or the time there it's
usually it's categorized by by
Effectiveness and Effectiveness is is
kind of more of a um measure of of of um
reasonableness you know we've ranked and
prioritize things by um by the best cost
benefit so the highest benefit for the
least cost is is what would rank highest
as we've ranked it yeah it might also
help for you to understand too that
these are
um these are
preliminary there there's as as the
commissioner said earlier there's
eligibility requirements that have to be
met for just the municipalities to even
be able to do this um so you know just
because it says you know say they're n
you know you have one number seven
versus 106 doesn't mean there may be
some municipalities that say you know
what we don't want to participate in
this program so the rank may actually be
higher because those
communities uh don't want to participate
they don't they don't want to you know
meet some of the requirements of the
type two
program represent Mills please I I just
we're getting close to winding this down
here just one last thing I just wanted
to if you could recap very quickly the
the things that you've already done in
tberry Lane here if I remember correctly
you've already put up Vegeta you've put
up BMS you put up Earth and BMS you've
done uh sound barrier plantings things
like that and I I guess it was kind of
news to me that you've already put up
some kind of a wooden sound barrier also
just so that the uh committee knows this
yeah no the concerns about tberry I mean
we we've we've we've taken them you know
real I I agree with everything the
senator said I've stood in those
backyards and it is and it is noisy um
number of years ago when it first came
up we couldn't build a sound wall but we
could build a a you know a stockade
fence for at least a privacy type of uh
thing um she's right The Stockade Fence
has since deteriorated or or or or um
you know had trees falling on it and and
stuff maintaining that Stockade Fence
has been um you know a a a challenge
it's
not
you know our guys are typically focus on
the roadway and plowing the roadway and
fixing the guard rail and then add off
100 feet off the road looking at the
looking at the fence so um it has fallen
into disrepair most recently because of
the current concern we have worked with
them and um it took a little bit of uh
doing and permitting because we had some
um additional Wetland impacts we are
looking at building a small burm closer
up toward the highway and a more robust
stockade fence um closer to the highway
on on on a burm so that it is uh you
know closer to Highway a better chance
of it being maintained and certainly
more um robust again we we've said it's
not it may have
some noise benefit but it's but it's not
dense enough it's not thick enough it's
not it's it's not um a noise mitigation
but it will address some of the privacy
and at least cut the cut the line of
sight so we've tried to do what we can
to address that and that will be going
forward but thank you you're welcome
thank you U if if I go ahead
representative you know I've been
sitting here thank you for taking my
question thank you Mr chairman I've been
sitting here listening to this
conversation it seems to have gone in a
circle it almost seems to me like this
bill says one thing and you're trying to
do another with it
um do people get a false hope that by
putting a sound barrier up they're going
to be able to sit out there and read
book you know you put some up and and
recent most recently the watchest the
toll booth you put some up and I heard
from a constituent this morning I live
basically through the woods from there
and they said it's just as noisy as ever
in fact it was quieter when the trees
were there but now the barrier is up in
a lot of areas so you know are you
getting feedback once you do a barrier
that people love it or they say boy this
really didn't help much or seems like a
lot of money to spend for maybe not
taking care of the
problem um John you can speak a little
bit further but they are effective to to
the to the to the uh to the houses or
The receptors that that benefit from it
um it won't benefit everybody there are
ones further away from the um sound
barrier that won't receive the benefit
um but that is a thing and and in
Rochester I know um because it did it
did come up as part of this part part of
this discussion around this bill I know
Senator richardi had concerns about
tberry Lane I think several other
senators were aware of um uh other noise
issues in in their uh districts I know
Senator gray had has had similar
concerns about the sound barriers in
Rochester um and um I think that's why
this bill morphed into a more um General
type of Bill to find a way to fund or
potentially fund a type 2 noise barrier
program um I'm I don't know if I'm
answering your question directly but um
that is part of the history the the the
one in
Rochester um there are some it's very
it's very similar to tberry lane or or
very similar to areas along the F ever
Turnpike where there are some
neighborhoods that meet the density
requirements and have a sound sound
barrier being built uh and it will be
effective for those communities there
are a couple other neighborhoods that
don't meet the density requirements are
not receiving a a noise barrier um and
I'm sure you're hearing from those folks
that that those are the ones that the
noise is as loud as ever
so you want to add anything more John
sure I can add the the noise barriers
we've done you know follow-up studies
post construction and and in general
they actually uh function better than
than and we're originally so in order to
determine how much benefit you're going
to get from a barrier we actually use a
noise model that's required by the
Federal Highway Administration because
obviously we can't make a decision uh
about the effectiveness of a barrier and
whether or not it should go in before
actually build you know we need to make
that decision before we actually build
it so we can predict the the noise
benefits from a barrier using that model
and then and then in actuality it
actually produces more benefit
a benefit is anything over 5 DB or
greater 5 DB is a noticeable difference
um and then uh because it's a
logarithmic scale approximately 8 to 10
DB is half the noise for the first row
homes behind a barrier those are the
ones that typically get the best the
most benefit uh generally we see on the
order of a 12 to 15 dbel reduction for
those first homes so they are seeing
more than half
the noise levels they're they're
certainly not ever going to see um you
know complete silence from for you know
we're never going to eliminate the
highway traffic noise because it is
still there but the idea is to
essentially disrupt the flow of noise
and in fact really what A noise barrier
is it noise dissipates over distance and
so if you put a noise barrier up and the
noise can't get through it has to travel
a further distance to get to the to the
the
adjacent homes and that is what's
causing the noise reduction so just by
putting in that barrier you you will get
a noise reduction from from that but
again it's not going to completely
eliminate it thank you thank you um one
one more question from myself if I
could so it's policy to use toll credits
when necessary to fund a project but I
would think most of that is is a Highway
project correct asphalt concrete those
sort of things and it would seem to me
that sound barriers while they're very
necessary and the people living
alongside um for the enjoyment of their
property I can understand that but I it
would seem to me that this is an
anciliary use of those
monies um and
um Mr Evans if if this is your only
charge I would think you should might
want to move into another department on
how you're going to fund these
things um I'll find plenty of work from
elsewhere if
that's I and um when when I saw and i'
I've been through this many times as
rent Mills is you know when you start
seeing that list turn into two pages
there there's a tremendous need we just
don't apparently have the the way to
fund that at this point in time um any
further questions from the Department
seeing none thank you so much for your
time thank
you so for the committee we are going to
have to Blue sheet uh thank you Kathleen
heck U New Hampshire Municipal
Association uh signed in in
favor uh we are going to need to convene
to exec the um the other Bill we had
earlier the naming bill so we might as
well hold off on this until that time
and as soon as we get an indication on
when that letter is going to be
forthcoming um we'll do that schedule so
I don't have any other business anyone
have any questions on the committee at
this point in
time Mr chair do you expect other Senate
bills that we will get Senate bills as
of today um I I believe this is what we
have in our in our I don't know what
what else is coming
okay thank you we are uh we are told um
that by next week we should be back in
our committee room great and as exciting
as that is I've been told three times we
were going to be there so say I heard
that before I think I'll believe it when
I see so uh thank you all for finding
your way here and we'll see you tomorrow
uh in rep's
Hall thank
you
e